non-minimalists
mason wants to know what advice do you
have for someone that's just
starting out that wants to have a
successful
film career like you like you matt yeah
this is me yeah cause you you don't
actually be pity you could mom no
i was i was just thinking it would be
funny like do you guys always put it in
the
in the show notes even if it's bad
because then i'm like just gonna say
something ridiculous
and then you have to quote it and then
people are looking at the website what
the heck is this well
if it's really if it's really dumb we'll
bleep it and we'll say it was profound
yeah and we'll make something like that
yeah
we could only share it on patreon oh
yeah that's right okay if you want to be
a successful
filmmaker um
if you want to be a success you want to
be a successful filmmaker like like you
like you
that's it yeah are you talking about me
you know
maybe another way to look at this matt
is like when you think about that
college kid even before you got out of
college like
what would what advice would you give
yourself when you were
at that point in your life well i think
if you want to find success
in any field you need to first define
what success is
that's that's it that's good no but like
really like you you have to figure out
what because he's like saying like if
you want to be successful like me
it really depends like a lot of times
what
it looks like i do isn't
actually what i do because like you see
like if you love my youtube videos or
you love
the um like the films that i make the
feeling that you get when
when you watch that isn't necessarily
the feeling that i have when i'm making
it
right it's still like a thrill i love
doing it's creative problem solving
but you really need to make sure that
you actually love the process of
filmmaking and whatever part of that
process it is whether it's the editing
or the directing or the filming
i happen to love all of it and so i
think you really have to make sure that
if you love what you do then i really
think that that's success and so
i mean it just takes ooh that's a good
pity one too if you love what you do
that's success yeah yeah that's great
it's good well matt
let me talk to you about that real quick
because i i and maybe it's a
generational thing ryan and i are
cuspers right we're
technically gen x or ryan is the
the youngest gen xer i know um
or it is true or he's the oldest
millennial i know yeah one or the other
yeah
and or maybe i'm the oldest millennial i
just claim whatever is convenient that
day is what i claim well here's the
thing what i've noticed people younger
than than me and ryan
and the younger it gets especially like
like
young millennials older gen z folks
they they define success by numbers
because we have
we've created a metric for everything
and when andrew schultz was on here he
goes i don't understand why jay-z wants
to be a billionaire
like now you're just the brokest
billionaire yeah
he's like or if you just convert if you
convert those dollars to
pounds now you're not a billionaire
anymore yeah
it also i think it's also like when we
see that when we see the numbers and i
know i certainly
felt this way like when you see somebody
who has two million or three million
subscribers on youtube
you think that that's like a feeling
like they have a
oh like now i have two million or three
but like whatever like you think it's
gonna
actually solve all of your problems and
i think this is like what we hear a lot
with people who
make a lot of money they realize that oh
i made all this money and i realized it
didn't make me happy
yeah so many people say well of course
like it's nice for you to say that
because you have all the money
but jim carrey said like who else is
gonna be able to say that from somebody
who's experienced it and realize it
actually doesn't bring happiness right
right
and like i can tell you firsthand uh
having zero subscribers and three
million
yes it allows me certain things it
allows me to create videos and like it's
amazing but like
i don't it doesn't change who you are it
shouldn't like
maybe there are some people who build up
these big followings and then their ego
gets inflated but i would say that those
people probably had egos to begin with
yeah
and that that following didn't help them
are you any happier at 3 million than
you were at 1 million or
2 million no i think that like obviously
like over the past couple years though
like i've had
ups and downs and like i've had to deal
with the the struggles of like the
pressure of creating for an
audience that wants to hear from you and
sometimes it's made you i mean just
based on your videos it's made you less
tranquil yeah it's decreased your
well-being because of chasing those
numbers right
yeah and not even intentionally chase
him and i will say matt it hasn't
changed you at all and i love that about
you
who you are as a person but there are
you felt some additional
pressure that probably decreased your
well-being yeah i think that that's
like if it did change me it added more
stress anxiety and pressure
which like that's what uh quote-unquote
like the
typical measures of success can do and
um
so i think that for me and also like it
does come to a degree and i know that
you guys feel this as well when you love
your work you pour yourself into it yeah
and it's hard to find that line of like
overworking and then burnout and like
how do i manage this and i think the
added pressure of people waiting to hear
from you maybe made that worse for me
and so you know just like we were
talking about earlier like minimalism
is about you continue to ask yourself
these questions about what you need and
it changes over time
you have to continue to check in with
yourself uh as a creator or as somebody
who's building an online following to
make sure that you're not doing it for
the metrics and you don't feel like you
have to do it
and that you actually want to do it and
you get to do it it's one of my favorite
things about netflix is they don't share
the metrics with us
yeah like i know just because of how
often people recognize us from the first
film i know a lot of people saw it but
i i can't tell you whether it was 30
million
or 70 million like and it doesn't really
matter i don't feel any more successful
today in 2021
than i did in 2011
because success for me
had involved a certain amount of freedom
and
and being financially free being
untethered to
obligations being unattached to the
desires
desire is great attachment is suffering
though right
my pithy answer for mason is no one can
be a better you than you
and i think the one of the problems we
seek is like hey how can i be matt
diabella well if you want to be an off
brand matt diabella
you could there are plenty of them out
there they come up in my youtube video
all the time oh it's nice i like it
i find it flattering hi i'm i'm that mia
the funny thing i see is like someone
tries to make videos like matt
and they use like our rules without
attributing it so it's like
they're taking the minimalist sort of
written philosophy yeah
they try to mimic matt's style and it
just comes off as like
it's a great point it's like you're
eating at a a fake
mcdonald's like a north korean
mcdonald's or something it's like
what this is i think yeah it's okay to
be inspired and i think that some
sometimes people confuse what maybe is
the thing so whether it's like
copying thumbnails and like i certainly
pulled tons of inspiration when i
started from other people and like what
was going to work for the thumbnail and
i think sometimes we confuse what's
actually the important part of that the
important ingredient
and i think if you're just getting
started out like copy my style do like
whatever it is so then you can learn
but you're probably not going to be able
to build an audience doing the same
thing that i did
just like casey neistat or peter
mckinnon and other youtubers that i
follow like
if i did exactly what they did i
probably wouldn't be successful well
it's interesting it makes me think about
how in other countries we have
like in portuga and brazil there's a
portuguese minimalism website that
someone has
literally copied and pasted everything
that we've done and they just have put
it into portuguese
and they have called it their own and
guess what they're not as successful
as us and that's for a couple reasons
like one
um they're not josh and ryan they're not
as awesome as us
but no really even if let's say you do
mimic someone perfectly
then like you said josh when someone
notices that oh
this person is mimicking the minimalists
then they become
a bit of an off brand like they don't
they don't uh
they're not as well regarded as as you
and i
uh maybe people do read their work and
they're great and it's great that it's
in portuguese and i'm actually grateful
that someone did that just so our work
can be you know
translated into portuguese but as soon
as someone sees like oh this is just an
off-brand josh and ryan
um that is gonna prevent them from i
don't know being successful or
getting the credit that they could be
getting by doing their own work
you